字幕: Takuma Suzuki
校正: Kazunori Akashi
私は大学一年生のときに
manmaという団体を立ち上げました
それから３年 家族留学という
取り組みを中心に展開をしています
家族留学というと
「家族で外国語を学びに留学に行くんですか」
と思われる方もいると思うんですけど
これは海外に留学に行くんじゃなくて
国内の子育て家庭に若者が留学に行く
そんな事業です
これ 右側が受け入れて下さった家庭
左側がカップルで家族留学に
参加した学生さんです
こんな風に 子育て家庭に
一日密着して 留学に行く
それを通して 自分自身の生き方を考え直す
そんなキャリアプログラムです
実はですね 左側のお二人 カップルなんです
自分たちの将来を一緒に考えたい
そんな思いで家族留学に
一緒に参加してくれました
最初「カップル留学したいです！」
って言われたとき
これは止めた方がいいのかなって
ちょっと思いました
お互いの人生観を すごく率直に話すので
もし合ってなかったら
「家族留学が原因で別れました」
とか言われたら
どうしようかなって思ったんですけど
でもこの二人も参加して お互いの人生
中々自分たちの将来のことって
改めて話すことってないですよね
お互いの将来の話をして
今まで参加したカップルたちは
すごく仲良くなってくれました
「別れないで続いてほしいなあ」と
いつも願いながら 家族留学をやっています
家族留学 何をするかというと
すごくシンプルです
特別なことをする訳じゃありません
こうやって子供たちと一緒に遊んだり
一緒にお昼ご飯を作ったりします
そして その場でわからないことは
どんどん聞いていきます
子供が泣いたときどうするんですかとか
これご夫婦で お二人で
手前の学生さんが話を聞いてるんですけど
例えば「お昼ご飯いつもどっち
作っているんですか？」とか
「どうしてこの人と結婚したんですか？」とか
「子供が生まれて変わったことって
何ですか？」とか
なかなか聞けないですよね
10個上 20個上の人たちに
そんなプライベートなことって
なかなか聞けない
でも その人のお家の中に入ったからこそ
その人たちの本当の姿を知って
本当の話を聞くことが出来ます
その中で得られた 沢山のヒントを元に
自分の人生を改めて考え直して
未来に前向きになってもらいたい
それが家族留学の企画です
なかなか就職活動のタイミングに
働くってことを考えるんですけど
ちょっとその時に将来の結婚・子育てっていう
働くの先も意識し始める人が
大学生世代に沢山出てきています
そんなときに 実際に
子育て家庭に行って話を聞く
その経験を通して
自分自身のキャリアを考えて
未来に前向きになってもらいたい
それが 家族留学のプログラムです
今では こんな風に
自分のプロジェクト「家族留学」について
皆さんの前でお話をするくらい
ちょっと勇気を持てています
でも 実は 大学一年生の夏
私は普通じゃないという風な診断をされました
パーソナリティー障害
そしてADHDという風に
病院で言われたことがあります
パーソナリティー障害っていうと
なかなか聞きなれない言葉かなと思います
パーソナリティー障害っていうのは
その人の持っている性格が
今の時代の社会的ルールとか 規範に合わない
そんな状態を指しています
例えば ずっと昔だと お殿様がいて
沢山のお嫁さんをとっていた
時代があったかもしれません
でも 今の時代にそれをやると
ちょっとおかしい人かなって
なっちゃいますよね
そんな風に 時代によって
社会のルールは違います
そして そのルールに合う部分
合わない部分があって
合う人 合わない人がいます
そのように 社会のルールに合わない
それをまとめて
パーソナリティー障害と呼んだりします
私自身は
自分がすごく悲しいなあと思ったときに
その気持ちをうまく整理できなくて
怒っちゃたりとか
気持ちを整理するっていうことに
あんまり得意じゃなかった
そんな性格を持っていました
それが自分自身も周りも
苦しめてしまうことがあった
だから パーソナリティー障害と診断された
そんなことがありました
普通になれない 普通にならなきゃ
ずっと私は葛藤していました
最初は病名なんてついてなかったんですけど
４年前のちょうど今頃
ここ札幌に旅行に来ていた時に
「あなたのその性格さすがにやばいから
病院行った方がいいんじゃない」
そう 当時一番仲の良かった
友達に言われました
すごくショックだったけど
その一言で踏ん切りがついて
一回病院に行ってみよう
そういう風に言って病院に行ってみたところで
この診断をされました
最初はすごくショックで
病名がついたこともすごくショックだったし
親しい人に責められたことも
すごくショックだったし
とにかくまずショックでした
でも何よりもすごくほっとしました
これまでは 私が普通じゃないから
普通にならなきゃいけない
私が普通じゃないからだれかを傷つけている
ずっとそう思っていました
ずっと頑張って
でも変われない自分を責めていました
でも 診断をされたことで
普通になれなかったんだ
がんばってどうにかなる問題じゃなかったんだ
そう思ったら
すごく肩の荷が下りた気がしました
そもそも
私が追い求めてた普通って何だったんだろう
そう考えるようになりました
嫌なことをされても笑顔でいなきゃいけない
悲しいって思ってもこらえなきゃいけない
世の中には 私以外にも
色んな普通を持っている人がいると思うんです
可愛くなきゃ 賢くなきゃ
コミュニケーション能力あって
友達がいっぱいいなきゃいけない
でもそんな普通って 実は誰かが決めたもので
実態がないんじゃないか そう思うようになりました
それから少しずつ 私は普通にならなきゃ
ていう気持ちから 解き放たれていく
そんな感じがしました
私はこの診断を受けたこと そして高校時代に
NPOカタリバという
NPOに出会ったことをきっかけに
少しづつ 普通じゃなくていい
そう思えるようになってきた気がします
NPOカタリバというのは
高校生向けに キャリア教育プログラムを
やっているNPOです
私はここで 沢山の大学生
そして社会人の先輩達に出会いました
私は大学を４年間で卒業して大きな会社に入る
それが普通だと思っていました
でも カタリバで出会った先輩たちは
体調を崩して大学を６年くらい
通っている人もいたし
最初に入った大学が合わなくて
辞めちゃった人もいました
私がこれまで知っていた普通とは
ちょっと違う人たちでした
でも だからといって
その人たちが何か劣っていることはなくて
普通じゃない人たちこそ すごく綺麗で
すごく楽しそうで すごく魅力的に見えました
今まで必死に追いかけていた普通を
別に追いかけなくてもいいんじゃないか
そう思うようになったし
自分自身の人生を自分自身で決めていく
そんなヒントを沢山もらった気がします
でも カタリバで出会った人たちは
キャリアのこと 仕事のこと
勉強のことばかりを教えてくれました
でも 私には昔から
もう一つ気になることがありました
将来 あったかい家族を作りたいなあ
ずっとそう思ってたんです
でも さっきみたいな診断をされて
近しい人との関係すら
私は上手く作れませんでした
そんな私には あったかい家族を作るなんて
一生かけても叶わないかもしれない
そう思っていました
でも カタリバで沢山の人に会って
自分の生き方のヒントをもらって
普通じゃなくていい
色んな考え方を知ることが出来ました
だったら それと同じで 沢山の家族に会って
沢山の家族からヒントをもらったら
自分自身のその夢を叶える
何かきっかけになるんじゃないか
色んな家族に会ってみたい
そういう風に思うようになりました
でも 当時の私は
人前で話すのも全然好きじゃなくって
委員長とか部長とか そういうような
リーダーシップを取るような経験とか
新しいことをするような
経験をしたことがありませんでした
そんな私にとっては 色んな家族に
アポイントを取って 会いに行って話を聞く
それはすごくハードルの高いものに
思われました
でも このまま 自分の夢が一生叶わない
かもしれない そんな気持ちを抱えて
頑張っても 頑張っても 近い人との関係を
上手く築けない
どう頑張っても変われない
その絶望の中にいるよりは
新しいことに挑戦して 死ぬほど失敗して
死ぬほど悔しい思いをする
そっちの方が
まだよっぽどましなんじゃないか
そういう風に思うようになっていきました
この辛い 辛すぎる
今を変えられるかもしれない
そんな思いで manmaという団体を
立ち上げることにしました
何もやったことのなかった私は
とにかく色んな家族を見たい
色んなママたちから話を聞きたい
そんな思いで 沢山のプロジェクトに
チャレンジをしました
働いているお母さんたちに声をかけて
インタビューをしました
そして 託児所に
インターンに行かせてもらって
家族っていうものを支える
そんな場所を見に行きました
色んな事を１年間トライしてみて
その結果たどり着いたのが「家族留学」でした
実際にその人たちの暮らしを体験して
その人たちのリアルな声を
その場で聞くことが出来る
その面白さが後押しをして
今は全国22の都道府県に広がっています
私もこの家族留学を通して
本当に沢山のことを学びました
お父さんお母さんたちも
すごく自分たちの生き方を模索していること
子育ては自分一人でするものじゃなくって
家族や周りも巻き込んで チームでやること
沢山の子育てをしているご家庭から
沢山のヒントをもらいました
そのことは 私の考え方や人との接し方を
大きく変えていきました
そして何より 生き方と同じで
家族の在り方にも普通なんてなくて
自分らしく 自分達らしくあっていい
そんなことを教えてもらいました
私は一度 普通じゃない
そんな診断をもらいました
でもその後 色んな病院を回って
色んな意見を求めに行きました
そしたら 最初はパーソナリティー障害って
言われたけど その後ADHDって言われて
その後 「まあ広い意味で
軽度の発達障害があるかもしれないですね
まあ 気にするほどのことじゃありませんよ」
そう言う先生もいました
つまり 私が何者か 私が普通か否か
それはお医者さんにも誰にも
決められないんじゃないか
どんどんそういう風に
思うようになっていったんです
ずっと普通になりたい
普通を追い求めていました
でも お医者さんだって普通は分からないし
人に会えば会うほど 普通なんてどこにもない
そういう風に思うようになっていきました
普通じゃない自分を許せるように
普通じゃなくて当たり前なんじゃないか
そう思うようになっていきました
そうしたら
少しずつ気持ちが楽になっていって
自分の出来ないこと 自分の苦手なことを
認められるようになりました
例えば 私ひとりじゃ
きっとmanmaは大丈夫だとか
私の未来はきっと楽しい
そんな風に 希望を持って生き続けることは
難しいときがあります
でも そんな時
「日南恵ちゃんならきっと大丈夫」
そう思ってくれる人がいたら
その私の足りない部分は少しずつ補完されて
私は少し前向きになることが出来ます
manmaというチームは
今10人くらいになります
でも 私はみんなの気持ちを
完全に分かってあげることは出来ません
そんな時に みんなと話すことが得意で
みんなの気持ちを考えることが得意な
仲間がサポートしてくれます
前は普通になりたくて
もっとみんなの気持ち分かるようにならなきゃ
感じ取れない私が悪いんだ
もっと前向きにならなきゃ
なんでこんなにチャレンジできないんだろう
普通になれない 自分のところを数えては
すごく自分自身を責めていました
でも出来ないんだって思うようになったら
自分自身を許せるようになったし
そのことを知って
沢山の人が助けてくれるようになりました
こうしてmanmaは全国に広がり
色んな企業とコラボレーションしたり
大学とコラボレーションしたり
自分じゃ思ってもみなかった所に
展開をしていきました
そして 受け入れ家庭の人達に教えてもらった
最も大事なことがあります
「家族はチームだ」
そう教えてもらいました
たった一回の数十年の人生
この人生を共に歩んでいくためのチームとして
私たちは家族を持っている
私たちはみんな どこか出来るところ
出来ないところがいっぱいあって
出来ないところがあるからこそ
自然と結びついて チームを作っていく
普通じゃないからこそ
人は結びつき合うんじゃないか
普通じゃないって すごく素敵なことだなあ
そう思うようになりました
誰かが決めた普通とか
自分が勝手に思い込んでいる
普通を追い求めるんじゃなくて
ただ自分一人として 出来ること
出来ないこと それを受け止めること
そして 出来ないからこそ助けてもらって
助けてあげて お互いに繋がり合っていく
そんな家族や団体や
そんな支えあえるチームが
これからもっともっと増えていったら
私たちの未来はもっと明るく
素敵なものになっていくんじゃないか
そう思っています
今日はお時間いただき
ありがとうございました
（拍手）